hey uh i don't you if you know me you
know i love a good conspiracy theory i i
just i just really do um and one that is
really funny
is about reptilians now maybe you don't
know what reptilian is that like a
reptile well it's like a reptile human
sort of blend like a reptil reptile-like
humanoid
um
this comes from a number of different
places but where we most recently saw it
this is crazy eric balling is now a news
max host
newsmax is a a crazier version of fox
news eric balling actually used to be on
fox news now he wasn't like a serious
reporter i'm not going to say that but
he was on fox news he was ultimately
pushed out of fox news because of sexual
uh harassment allegations against him on
newsmax he seriously devoted a segment
to maybe former president barack obama
was a reptilian check this out back in
2013. look at that you see that obama
visited the middle east and gave a
speech an ordinary speech but allegedly
a reptilian was identified in the crowd
a secret service agent with very unique
features
either way people ran with it and if you
can believe this they even created a
list on how to identify lizard people
interesting obama did have low blood
pressure he doesn't wear glasses he does
love science
that's right remember when he invited
that clock kid to the white house
inspiring a little scientist who made a
clock built it into a suitcase wires
hanging out all over with a countdown
all very alarming don't you think and he
submitted the project to school well the
worst thing could have happened the
suitcase started beeping people thought
it was a bomb the teacher called the
cops parents were upset it was all whole
ordeal but i bet if clock kid brought
that to the white house unannounced it
would ruffle some feathers now okay so
eric balling barely able to read off of
the teleprompter some people are saying
that he's not taking the conspiracy
theory seriously others are saying he
clearly is it kind of doesn't matter the
fact that they're even explaining uh
talking about these claims in this way
is absolutely bizarre so for those who
don't know i i really do love this stuff
reptilian conspiracy theories um they're
sometimes they call them reptoids
reptiloids or lizard people these are
supposed reptilian humanoids and the
idea of reptilians goes back to david
icke david icke is a conspiracy theorist
who has claimed that shape-shifting
reptilian aliens control earth
because they take on a human form so
they pass as humans and then they use
their intelligence combined with their
fake human form to gain political power
and then they manipulate human societies
and ikky has previously stated that
there are lots of world leaders either
who are reptilian or are possessed by or
controlled by reptilians and there are
adherents of the q anon conspiracy
theory
who borrow a lot of stuff from
reptilians you know with with all of
these things this is a particularly
funny one to me now i know that you can
say this one is
damaging in the sense that the people
that believe it often are also
anti-semitic they talk about uh you know
uh globalists globalist yeah uh and all
of this stuff but by itself it's just
kind of dumb and of course we have to
some at some point apply an occam's
razor to it
this just seems really complicated and
if they could take on
this human form
why would they do it in a way that they
would be identifiable like that infamous
video it's like a weird grainy angle of
some secret service agent that he was
talking about that's really old they've
brought that up before
why would they take such a reptilian
form if they have such advanced
technology and they're so smart
why couldn't they just design it so that
they look past like humans i mean none
of it makes sense but the fact that
newsmax is putting this stuff up as if
it's really a topic of discussion shows
us how far we've fallen it's even beyond
fox news i think although maybe not i'd
have to go back and review some of the
fox news segments eric balling from fox
news host
to sexual harassment claims to getting
fired
although officially they parted ways
amicably
to spreading
ideas about reptilians on newsmax my how
the mighty have fallen remember that on
monday memorial day we will have a one
day membership special we can uh offer
you this special
only on a holiday
because our entire team will be on break
so they won't know that we're kind of
giving away the farm with such a big
discount i would love for you to sign up
for a membership at joinpacman.com
but if you want the biggest discount
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com monday memorial day
you'll get an email telling you exactly
how to sign up
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever spend
time planning when what time of day do i
need to take each one i just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below